Gonna be late. I know look good. Yes water that came from your thigh gap. No, thank you. Thanks for calling it again
With celebrity chef Sascha Trek and her fiancé Brandon Choi. What a great cause huh?
You're opening a new restaurant and they need you in San Francisco
Hey, hi Marcus, yeah. Hi Sasha. Hi. Hello. Hi long time
Yes, yes very long time was it
Salsa twist and you're like her own agent Oprah. How much money do you have now?
It's serious
I'm surprised you two lost touch. He used to be so close
So when is the big wedding day he wants to travel a bit before we settle down it's really for the both of us
I finally realized that I don't want to marry you
Shit, I can tell you're a little bit. Okay mom area and shit yourself to get you shitty piece of shit
Softer place you are scary
I guess I have to start dating again. Oh there anything worse you and Marcus are so cute
Remind me why you never got together. There's way too much history there
You still have the Corolla
What are you looking at my back seat because we had sex back there. Oh my god
What do you think that it might be even smaller and grosser than I remember. Hey, you better still be talking about my back seat
They don't want to wonder what is
How do you feel so I had some news so do I thank mines big - okay look
Wow, that's that's so great. We have the most insane freaky ass sex. I can't even talk about it. Otherwise I was talking about
There he is
Hi baby I missed your thigh. Mr. Pierce. Gotcha I missed your taste